we're on problem 110 scroll this up 110
whenever Martin has a restaurant bill
with an amount between ten dollars and
ninety nine dollars he calculates the
dollar amount of the tip is two times
the tens digit of the amount of his bill
fair enough so essentially if there is a
ten cent he just multiplies it by two if
the amount of Martin's most recent
restaurant bill was between ten and
ninety nine fair enough was a tip
calculated by Martin on his bill greater
than 15% of the amount of the bill so
was tip greater than 15% that is the
question
statement one says the amount of the
bill was between 15 and 50 dollars
fifteen and fifty dollars so one it will
essentially is enough for this problem
is sufficient if every for every bill
based on his calculation where you
double the tens digit it's going to be
greater than fifteen and I suspect let's
see if we take the lower end of this on
this he'll pay two dollars right he'll
pay $2 tip on 15 and what percentage is
that 15 goes into 2.0
11550 15 goes into 50 three times three
times 50 45 and it just keeps going so
that's a 13% tip so if we're closer to
well I guess it's never gonna well it's
going to be even lower than that at $16
right
maybe the bill wasn't fifteen the bill
was $16 so the tip is I don't know at
the lower end it's 13 12% and at the
higher end if it's on if the bill is oh
I don't know let's say the bill is $40
exactly if the bill is $40 exactly and
he pays he would pay $8 on that right if
the bill is 40 then bill would pay $8
which would be 20% so I can pick
different numbers in this range and
based on the way bill calculates his tip
oh no not bill I don't know how I got
that name oh they said the amount of the
bill right depends how Martin calculates
his bill he he can either pay less than
15% or more than
Dean percent so statement one alone is
not sufficient what a statement to tell
us the tip calculated by Martin was $8
so the tip is equal to $8 well this is
going to be 2 times the tens digit so
that means that the bill was equal to 40
I don't know 40 something right so let's
think about it if the bill so the worst
case is if if the bill if you paid $8 on
a $40 bill that's definitely more than
15% right that's 8 of 40 that's 20%
that's what I just actually calculated
but if you paid it let's see the worst
case is on a $49 bill that the bill
keeps going up and he just pays $8 so 8
is 8 bigger than 15% of 49 well yeah
because 8 over 58 over 50 is equal to
what it see that's equal to 16 percent
right so if 8 over 50 is 16 percent 8
over 49 if we lower the denominator a
little bit that's going to be greater
than 16 percent so no matter what range
in the 40s the bill was whether it's $40
or $49 or anything in between an $8 tip
is going to be more than it's actually
going to be more than 16 percent not not
to speak of even 15% so statement number
two alone is sufficient to answer this
question and statement number one is
fairly useless problem 111 the price per
share of stock X increased by 10 percent
over the same time period that the price
per share of stock Y decreased by 10
percent the reduced price per share of
stock Y was what percent of the original
price per share of stock X fascinating
so let's do initial and final so the
price so X final is equal to it
increased by 10 percent from the initial
period okay so it equals one point one
times X initial fair enough and then
over the same time period y decreased by
10 percent so Y final is equal to
10% less than Y initial so that's 0.9
times y initial and what they want to
know is the reduced price per share of
stock Y so that's why F was what percent
of the original price per share of stock
X of X initial so this is what they want
to figure out this is a percentage so
let's see if the statements help us out
at all the increased price per share of
stock X was equal to the original price
per share of stock Y so the increased
price per share of stock X so that's XF
that's the final that's the increased
share price right an increase from the
initial to the final so that increased
price per share of stock X was equal to
the original price per share of stock Y
so that equals Y initial y initial so
this is interesting I don't know if it
gets us anywhere this deals with X final
and X initial so I think we can so we
could bright right if we could write all
of it in terms of Y initial so Y final
equals so let's rewrite this this is
equal to Y final is point nine times y
initial
right that's just from this equation 0.9
times y initial
and let's see if we could write the
initial x in terms of in terms of
initial Y so X final is equal to Y
initial so that means that Y initial is
equal to this so that equals one point
one X initial and that means that we can
divide both sides of this equality by
one point one and we get X initial is
equal to one over one point one times y
initial right so then we have this one
over one point one times y initial
and then these two would cancel out
and you would actually have your answer
so statement one alone is sufficient to
answer the question and it wasn't
obvious to me at first but then you have
to realize that the terminology is
confusing but that you can actually
write both of these in terms of
y-initial given that information given
the fact that X final is equal to Y
initial let's see what statement 2 does
for us the increase in the price per
share of stock X was 10 xi the decrease
in the price per share of stock Y let me
think about that the increase in the
price per share of stock X so that means
that X final minus X initial right
that's the increase that this was equal
to 10 over 11 times the decrease in the
price per share of stock Y so what was
the decrease this was Y initial minus y
final minus y final because this was a
larger number and we wanted a positive
number here cuz we're just saying the
decrease we're not saying you know the
negative increase so let's see if we can
simplify this at all if we can simplify
this at all so let's see you get well
you get X final minus X initial is equal
to 10 11 Y initial minus 10 11 y final
and remember the whole time we just want
to figure out what Y final over X
initial our Y final over X initial so
let's think about this
so X final minus the next let's write X
X final is equal to one point one times
X initial right so we have one point one
times X initial minus X initial is equal
to actually I should have done that in
the first step let's just skip this
right now let's just write the 10 over
11
10 over 11 we want what do we want in
the fund we want Y final so we just want
to substitute for Y initial so Y initial
sorry I'm confusing myself so Y initial
is going to be equal to Y final divided
by 0.9 so 1 over 0.9 Y final and it's a
little confusing minus y final I just
did a substitution for y initial
and then here well this is actually we
know that this is we can solve this
problem although it gets quite hairy
because here if you think about it
you're gonna get some number you're
gonna get well you're gonna get 0.1 X
initial is equal to you know 1 divided
by point you're gonna get some constant
after you do all this math times y final
y final and so you can easily figure out
what Y final divided by X initial is
just by dividing both sides by X initial
and then dividing both sides by a and
you would have solved the problem and
I'm not gonna do that because it's
actually kind of hairy and I don't have
you know 1 divided by 0.9 and then
multiplying it by 10 11 is a fairly
convoluted way of doing it but hopefully
you see that this is solvable and let me
just review that again because I think I
I did in my own head in a little secure
dissuasive a statement itself said the
change the gain in X X final minus X
initial was 10 11 times the loss in Y so
Y initial minus y final cuz Y final was
a smaller 1x final we can rewrite in
terms of X initial just using our
initial the fact that it was 10% more so
I just did that here right and Y initial
we can rewrite as Y final Y initial you
could say Y initial is equal to Y final
divided by 0.9 and that's what we did
there and then you can see here this
will simplify to some constant times y
final and you multiply that times 10 11
so you get some constant times y final
and then you have point one times X
initial right one point one minus one
and then you can just do some simple
algebra to figure out what Y final over
X initial is so both statements
independently are sufficient to solve
this problem I think that was the
hardest one we've done so far see in the
next video